llamo
gustavo petro
es
un momento histórico para colombia con
más de 11,2 millones de votos el
izquierdista gustavo petro ganó la
presidencia después de varios intentos
por llegar a la casa de nariño superó a
su oponente por alrededor de 700 mil
votos en unas elecciones con la
participación electoral más alta en los
últimos 20 años
22,6 de los 39 millones de colombianos
salieron a las urnas el equivalente al
58 por ciento de participación al
conocer los resultados
gustavo petro dio su primer discurso
como mandatario el cambio significa que
esta esperanza puede hacer y llenar
todos los rincones del territorio
nacional el izquierdista tuvo la
victoria principalmente en las regiones
costeras del país aunque bogotá la
capital se desmarcó del centro de
colombia y aportó más de 2,2 millones de
votos al triunfo de petró las elecciones
más o menos
mostraron dos colombias
cercanas en términos de votos
nosotros queremos que colombia en medio
de su diversidad sea una colombia aparte
del histórico logro de la izquierda en
el poder es la primera vez que el país
sudamericano tiene una vicepresidenta
mujer afrodescendiente
[Aplausos]
[Música]
saludos a las mujeres de colombia a
todas
mis hermanas
mis comadres
gracias por haberme acompañado vamos las
mujeres a erradicar el patriarcado de
nuestro país pero también se refirió a
los más de 10 millones de votantes de su
oponente rodolfo hernández dijo que
quiere desarrollar el capitalismo del
país y aseguró que espera posicionar a
colombia como una potencia en
latinoamérica
[Música]